und ich denke da gibt es zwei positive
nachrichten aus der bundeswehr in dieser
woche und zwar zum einen wurde die
debatte um die bewaffnung von drohen
beendet jeron tp ich bin selber
ausgebildeter tactical operator war
sechsmal im auslandseinsatz und bin ganz
ganz froh dass soldaten jetzt besser
geschützt werden wenn sie im einsatz
unter feuer stehen und dass die dort
eben nicht mehr warten müssen bisschen
kampfflugzeug kommt sondern mit
wirksamer luftaufklärung und bei bedarf
eben auch mit dem effektor seiner bombe
auf deutsch gesagt gestützt werden
können das haben wir beschlossen und ich
denke mal viele tote könnten auch
vielleicht noch leben die gefallen sind
in den auslandseinsätzen wenn wir das
früher gehabt hätte und der zweite punkt
der mich freut ist heute hat der
haushaltsausschuss beschlossen 2,4
milliarden zur verfügung zu stellen auf
antrag der ministerin bis 2025 komplette
persönliche schutzausstattung und
ausrüstung der bundeswehr zu erneuern
das heißt es geht um 305.000
schutzwesten über 150.000 neue kampf
kleidungs setzte und über 120.000 helmer
und rucksäcke also es geht darum
letztlich soldaten sicherer und besser
auszustatten im inland und im ausland
ist der erste schritt quasi zu einer
besser ausgestatteten bundeswehr und ich
denke mal das zeigt auch
handlungsfähigkeit überfällig längst die
hülle für ja gut aber sie will jetzt
aber nicht sagen nein ich kann doch so
kann unser kind gescheitert in der lose
you tube diesmal dielitz
zwei unterhaltungen haben in einer
wendung eine eine frage an sicherheit
ist es berührt sie ja auch sie haben ja
auch geschrieben dass etwas auf ihn auch
mit dem drohen was sie selber sehr
berührt weil sie da auch ein eigenes
erlebnis eigentlich haben oder damit
verbinden mit der schlechten ausstattung
ja es war vor zwölf jahren also im april
2010 nach dem karfreitags gefecht nicht
weil junger zugführer leutnant aus der
uni in meiner ersten verwendung und ich
durfte mit meinem zug die drei
gefallenen kameraden der karfreitags
gefechte beerdigen musste die beerdigen
das ist ein tag den ich wirklich nie
vergessen werde und ich habe das ganze
nochmal ausschuss auch gesagt dass ich
wenn ich mir jetzt überlegen diese
debatte die wir geführt haben 13 jahre
die dazu geführt dass soldaten eben
nicht optimal geschützt wurden wie wir
hätten schützen können dass das dass wir
das bitte in gedanken haben sollen wenn
wir solche entscheidungen fällen und was
ich immer an diese drei kameraden denken
dass die dort gefallen sind wirklich
spiegelbildlich für viele viele andere
die dort ihr leben gelassen haben kann
es eigentlich sein dass wir in den
ganzen jahren egal in welcher partei
eine pazifismus debatte geführt haben
die wir irgendwie nicht zu ende gedacht
haben nach der schönen devise nie wieder
krieg das habe ich immer so
interpretiert nie wieder krieg von
deutschen boden sprich als deutschen
angriffskrieg dass hier das was wir zwei
mal gemacht haben
und
war es dann also falsch zu sagen wir
binden wir kümmern uns auch nicht um
andere sachen wir müssen uns nicht
verteidigen und greift ja wohl keiner
mehr an ist also der pazifismus
überdehnt worden und haben wir da nicht
auch bei anderen ich viel zeit verloren
und wir hätten das was jetzt passiert
natürlich auch schon in den letzten
jahren tun muss und dass die bundeswehr
nicht also im grunde wieder mal nur
bedingt abwehrbereit war wie schon
einmal vor vielen jahrzehnten als jetzt
der spiegel -herausgeber ins gefängnis
musste das gilt ja jetzt wieder nur
jetzt regen wir uns nicht so aufs passt
jetzt in die landschaft also er prima
wir beide waren ja in einer diskussion
unserer partei über den nato
doppelbeschluss ja die der damals auch
zum sturz von schmückt
beigetragen hat weil die spd nicht mehr
wir müssen uns zwar wenn sie dass unsere
aufarbeitung jetzt der letzten jahre
erwähnen wir müssen unsere verhältnisse
sondern hat nun mal klärt die wird ja
immer so als eine feindselige dieser
sache angesehen auch von den deutschen
als ob sie uns bedroht die natur in
allen ich glaube wer ohne nato hätten
wir keine wiedervereinigung bewusst hat
sie sollten ja auch die zwei prozent
einheiten deshalb ist was machen ja auch
ihr während ihr den 2
die drogen im spiel ist das was er da
gesagt hat auch wirklich jetzt ein held
ist ein kleiner baustein die
drogengeschichte aber ich glaube die
herr bremer die interne und externe
wahrnehmung ist bei uns sehr
unterschiedlich also wie sie das
beschrieben haben dieser pazifismus in
deutschland nie wieder krieg was er sehr
richtig und berechtigt war ich glaube
wir müssen jetzt immer mehr unserer
rolle in europa gerecht werden als
bevölkerungsreichstes land als stärkste
volkswirtschaft und da sind ganz andere
erwartungen auch an uns gerichtet mit
denen wir selber gar nicht so gut klar
kommen mit unserer bevölkerung ich
glaube daran müssen wir uns gewöhnen
dass wir jetzt ja auch das volle bündeln
neben und eben keine scheckbuch
diplomatie in den 80er jahren betreiben
und unsere vergangenheit verpflichtet
uns geradezu dem bedrängten demokratien
zu helfen außerdem vor allen dingen
starten die von uns in schlimmster weise
opfer geworden sind die osteuropäischen
staaten also den sie zu helfen im
hinblick auf unsere vergangenheit ist ja
absurd nicht zu helfen ja ist ja absurd
trotzdem muss ich dann ein bisschen
nicht widersprechen unbedingt aber doch
einen kleinen einwand machen das ist
richtig was sie sagen wir bauen was
rechtfertigt nicht die in meinen augen
unsäglichen auftritte des ukrainischen
botschaft dass der hier
situationen ebenfalls ob das als opfers
immerhin hat er hat steinmeier findet
also manchmal was für sage es wieder
anders sehen wir lassen uns rechts links
ohrfeigen ob wir gute argumente haben zu
sagen was sie wollen geht so nicht es
geht erstens nicht dass wir jede werfen
lieferung über die bild zeitung in
einzelheiten genau vor können auch den
weg möglich zu erkennen damit sie
rechtzeitig torpediert werden können es
geht nicht dass wir überhaupt liebe ein
thema das nunmal geheimhaltungs
bedürftige alles in ordnung aber der
bekannt gegeben wurden also die haben ja
auch ich hatte doch bestellung der
ukraine
sind
es scheint ja doch lange zeit gedauert
zu haben bis mehr geliefert wurde also
das ist jetzt so schön darzustellen ist
ja nicht so also jetzt zieht man den
druck ob diese wirklich schrecklichen
gräueltaten und ich bin auch froh dass
man jetzt mehr machen möchte aber es hat
ja ewig gedauert also wir haben noch
erlebt und der botschafter hat uns schon
vorher hat uns ja auch der wusste ja
schon dass der angriff kommt ihr habt ja
gibt mittel um geprügelt und jetzt gebe
ich ihnen recht er ist sozusagen nicht
diplomatisch korrekt und es gefällt wird
vom 2 aber genau das tun er ist war und
jetzt verstehe ich und erkennt um sein
land erkennt und seine leute die sterben
wie die fliegen und erkämpft und das
recht richtigen haltung jeder am tisch
aber ich würde gerne noch mal auf herr
bremer zurückkommen ich glaube da eint
uns beide etwas ich habe als herr wenig
hier auch bei uns im studio war ihm auch
zwei drei kritische
frage stellen auch wieder wollte ich
auch glaube ab und an und das haben sie
ja auch gerade gesagt ist es ja auch die
vor wie man etwas ruhe bringt die
verzweiflung versteht ja jeder aber was
stört sie genau an dem entwurf schafft
die art und weise wie er sich im grunde
aufführt als habe er zu bestimmen was
wir zu machen aber er gibt uns ein ganz
schlechtes gewissen dass wir nicht die
ganze bundeswehr gleich los schicken ob
wir haben doch gezögert wir haben eine
wm wurden doch zum jagen getragen in
einigen haben das auch so eins dieser
urteile schnell fallen wir wurden immer
zum jagen getragen hat man sich darauf
zu recht vernünftig überlegt wir haben
eine konstellation auch in dieser
koalition wo das was jetzt stolz durch
gesetze überhaupt noch nicht in
trockenen tüchern ist bin mal sehr
gespannt ob das so einfach läuft bei den
stimmungslagen bei den grünen in der spd
wo der pazifismus immer noch da ist die
sind jetzt unter schockstarre
weil sie der schweiz überrollt hat aber
das dauert das ge bundestagsbeschluss
hat bin ich mal sehr gespannt die grünen
fangen doch an nicht nur für bagdad ex
lag das ist alles in ordnung ist alles
wahrheit kann ich was ist in trockenen
tüchern aber sicher welche ähnlich ganz
gut die grünen das ist nicht immer wird
auch die union bei uns sein denn ich
glaube nicht dass die union sagen wird
wir stehen 100 milliarden für die
bundeswehr nicht zu aber warum nicht
heute haben sagte endlich nicht
zugestimmt werden doch ihren eigenen
kanzler stürzen
ich liebe immer weil das ist so ein
typischer scholz blase ja ewig
verhindern weil man ja das geld hier
etwas anders einsetzt und dann kommt 100
milliarden
im bundestag ist man sich nicht einig
also ich möchte einfach nur sagen das
ist eine typische staat 100 auf einmal
wir sind natürlich froh dass wir endlich
was kriegen deshalb wird es weitgehend
auch mitmachen aber viel wichtiger ist
es die kontinuierlichen 2 prozent das
ist wie gesagt hey auf einmal alles raus
und den zehnern ist schon wieder
veraltet leiden das ist das richtige und
da höre ich ihn jetzt zum schluss um
nicht mehr jetzt wieder nur noch von den
100 milliarden reden wenn die zwei
prozent sind schon verschluckt das
stimmt ja auch das stimmt ja
unterscheiden dass da immer man seine
verpflichtungen erfüllt und dass auch
die bevölkerung versteht und da gebe ich
ihnen völlig recht herr bremer das
natürlich auch bereit sein muss um
abschreckung abschreckende wirkung zu
entfalten das ist leider auch
erforderlich weil es ist nicht so sind
nicht alle menschen gut so sehr sich das
immer alle menschen